i get a kick out of and this is why i
like
old rich people yeah but you like old
american rich
there's another level to that
in the south of europe yeah i like old
european rich too i think you need to
indulge in that here's i would love to
yeah what i like about them is they are
funny a little eccentric they're
ridiculous people
um it's a secret very small club
they don't
really parade themselves around as much
they are kind of insulated and insular
and there it's interesting like you know
i remember
me and him were eating ice cream in
montauk once and my friend
my friend works for a guy that i think
just last year made like a billion
dollars and i laughed i just looked at
ben and i said there's something funny
to me
about last year
earning a billion dollars yeah i just
started laughing yeah i couldn't even
explain it there was just something it's
something innately funny so to me these
families that have been so rich for so
long
uh and they have all these weird feuds
and
inbred infighting
secrets and [ __ ] and they shape the
world you know not all of it not
everything but there's shape a lot of it
dude it's actually hard to but you
nepotism going yeah it is no like i mean
that for surely yeah kids are retards
that is the problem the kids are retards
so like the knicks for example james
dolan owns the knicks yeah you're
familiar with the dolan family for sure
the board of the directors for the
knicks like five of them have the last
name dolan right now the knicks haven't
won since the 70s yeah now are you
telling me james dolan that the best way
to increase shareholder profits
the most effective people just happen to
be in your family
right there's nobody outside of your
family that might be more qualified
to make me [ __ ] money right nobody so
the that the crazy like that's the thing
about mafia exists it's so weird like
mafia needs violence right because
nepotism creates idiots yes if the mafia
could just outsource talent yeah they
wouldn't need to kill people they'd find
ways to legitimize the business yes and
then there's no issue but because your
son's an idiot
you need to murder the competition yes
instead of finding ways to like lobby
politicians to make your business legal
yes so in a weird way
nepotism
kills
institutions it does you it does but the
i guess it starves them of talent of
talent now the thing about mafia which
is nice is you get to like raise your
employees yeah the problem with bringing
in talent is they eventually they're
sharks
that's right yeah that's right so that's
the tricky thing about it but but yeah
nepotism like i'm actually impressed
when a family can keep
their [ __ ] together
for centuries yeah like look at the
medicis in [ __ ] italy they last a
hundred years crazy or i don't know
maybe it's a little longer than that
it's probably longer but still it's like
nothing it's a blip
it to me the kennedys are broke yeah
yeah these are broke not all of them but
some of them the majority of the
candidates
are a name yeah so they're no longer an
institution they couldn't keep it going
that [ __ ] joe kennedy they're not
relevant the bushes the bushes are not
relevant
bush's still got bread
they got bread but the kennedys probably
have just as much money they're just not
relevant anymore in the way that they
were right i mean they they were running
the the show for a little bit
of you know like people have you read
about joe yes he orches he was like my
son's gonna be president and it wasn't
even jfk it was the other son yeah right
and then something happened to the other
side maybe he was killed in war some
[ __ ] like that but like they crafted
jfk's whole story about what happened
the whole thing it was orchestrated by
this most of what you read about a lot
of these politicians is a creation it's
a narrative that's invented and that's
one of the things that i find very
interesting about about those really
wealthy families is that they can push a
narrative they have institutional
backing with media
you know with academia and they the way
that these uh stories go out they're
repeated so many times they're not true
yeah but they're they come true but they
become true and people like them yeah so
for me like what we were going back to
is like are you going to have the
homeless guys in the house it's like
no
unless they're like hung and respectful
yeah but for me it was like
it was always like i like the real
reality of what's going on even if it's
disturbing because
that's where i could make some kind of
fun of it yes like if i can confront it
then that's where i can make fun of it
but i i it's not that i'm some type of
altruist or i'm out there i'm not
giving people soup on the highway but i
do like sometimes i think the reality
like
the real story of the bush family's
success is much more interesting talk to
me than the story that's put out right
the real story
the real story is that a connecticut
preppy
bankers that descended from a preacher
who's you know if you trace the bush
family all the way back they're uh their
samuel bush
it was either samuel or his father was a
minister and he ministered to very
wealthy people in in connecticut and he
became friends with very wealthy people
and the family just started doing the
bidding of very very wealthy people and
depressed scott bush became a senator
and george h.w bush uh became you know
this ambassador to trump who's a cia
agent and all this stuff like this very
interesting thing and then you know they
were presented to us as kind of this
like texas free-spirited
you know they just they're watching
america connecticut these are
connecticut boring belt buckles and
everything you know kenny bunk poor mane
eating uh lobster salad
and it's just they were able to invent
this image of like i'm a gunslinging
free you know and that's very
interesting to me like being able to do
that on a massive scale when everyone
knows you are from connecticut and
doesn't care when everyone kind of knows
the truth and it doesn't matter because
you've laid the there's the fiction on
so things it's impressive it's called um
mandela effect
yes mandela effect where it's like
berenstein bears berenstain bear
whatever we just say ends up becoming
the reality that's choosing this [ __ ]
reality that's right so we might as well
choose the best version that's here for
100 years too the people in the tents
are having fun they love it that's a
good point they they've chosen that
ground that's right they're with their
friends they are with their friend they
have a great time here's what i will say
they uh do you seem crazy i do seem to
know each other
um
i don't see them crying i've heard
wailing i've heard wailing but whaling
might be happy yeah
yeah for sure